je reçois maintenant la dessinatrice
claire bretécher pour la parution de sa
bd agrippine est l'ancêtre le cinquième
tome des aventures d'agrippine dans
lequel la maman des frustrés portraiture
avec toute la verdeur de la caricature
lévis et des caprices de l'âge mûr bref
quand bretécher nous dépeint la
vieillesse elle nous derrida soir alors
agrippine est l'ancêtre 64 pages 64
francs édité par l'auteur vous faites
toujours de l'autoédition pourquoi vous
avez décidé de vous passer des éditeurs
hausse et par la parano des auteurs
beaucoup au départ parce que on croit
toujours que le lecteur se quittent pas
bien de vous parce qu'on va pas assez et
c
et puis comme on a fait une petite un
petit essai avec l'écho des savanes 72
donc je savais un peu comment fallait
voir un photographe se rapportent plus
d'argent ça rapporte 30 % jeudi pourrait
bien je fais pas maintenant quand même
vous vendez mais à une époque où l'on
dit 400000 exemplaires du tout bien sûr
avec 80 sont vivre maintenant ce que
beaucoup de ses pas ouais vous avez fait
quoi tout votre argent
j'ai acheté une maison dans le lubéron
non à 2 donc tu ne manges bretagne et
une à montmartre à mon mari paraît que
vous payez gf oui oui il suffit d'avoir
un appartement à wayne appartements et
maisons de campagne
évidemment vous avez bien bien très bien
alors agrippine est l'ancêtre donc le
premier agrippine c'était en 88
et là c'est le tome 5 alors pourquoi
d'un seul coup après pourrait vous
intéresser au quatrième âge ça m'est
tombé dessus je crois que c'est parce
que j'y arrive
non j'ai toujours aimé les vieilles
dames et puis je sais pas j'étais amené
à avoir une allée voir quelqu'un dans
une maison de retraite ces dernières
années ça nous arrive un peu à tous par
moments j'ai été fasciné par par sega
mais ça va être bon là votre espèce de
jeanne calment qui fait chier tout le
monde
oui c'est l'arrière grand-mère
d'agripper
donc elle s'est fâchée avec sa fille
parce que sa fille avait épousé un
communiqué un bolchevik alors on
retrouve votre méchanceté quoi votre
travail votre méchanceté c'est pas la
méchanceté c'est un trait acéré qui est
très comment vous définiriez vous nous
définir moi y'a bart qu'elle a dit
quelque chose de très gentil sur vos
roland barthes avis il était bourré
compte meilleures sociologue français
descendent quand il fallait qu'ils
remplissent un truc
ouais dites moi alors vous avez une
enfance bourgeoise et catholiques à
nantes 1
vous n'êtes pas le droit de lire pas le
droit de dessiner c'est ça votre mère et
mon enfance et moi on se parle plus
beaucoup et que moi je lui trouve aucun
charme et voilà vous êtes tiré un trait
dessus que oui enfin votre mère quand
même préféré que vous travaillez plus
tôt que plutôt que chercher à tout n'est
pas négatif
absolument vous a pas dit d'épouser un
officier de cinq ans quand vous êtes
arrivé à paris c'était il ya longtemps
vous étiez raisonnée quand même vous
n'êtes pas mal galéré
oui bon s'agit pas plus que tout les
toutes les filles qui arrivait à paris
dans les années 60 personnes le régime
commun à vous en parler bien vous dit
j'étais un peu gourde complètement
fauchée
j'habitais dans un carton j'adore je
vivais avec un minable
c'était une période atroce fallait
apporter toutes les 5 minutes et trouver
quelqu'un chez qui squattaient c'est
bien ça s'apprend oui voilà un jour
helbecque cela mais comment ça c'est que
c'est pas arriver à finir le roman de
houellebecq parce que c'est aussi cru
que houellebecq ce parce que j'ai oublié
en bretagne mais bon ça vous a plu le
début le début m'a plu c'est vous quoi
ces espèces de traits comme ça sert et
sais pas j'aime bien le personnage dans
ses interviews mais pour ces jeunes
absolument finir se livrer sans vraiment
de l'ordinaire et des biens non mais
c'est comme ça alors vous avez commencé
à bosser chez bayard c'est ça oui vous
allez bosser aussi à ici paris france ou
net ça oui parce que je vendais des
salles et des cartoons qu'avec la ligne
dessous parce que c'était payé tout de
suite et 50 50 mais c'était correct
ouais c'est travailler alors on 63 pour
rencontrer goscinny
oui alors vous êtes d'abord travaillé
avec lui puis après vous êtes partie du
trajet puis vous l'avez retrouvé j'ai
pas partie outrage et il m'a jetée en me
disant que je savais pas travailler ce
qui était un truc de vérité ça m'a même
pas vexer ce mec a raison et je suis
revenu après alors vous l'avez retrouvé
évidemment en 65 ans 69 décret cellulite
qu'un de vos premiers grands succès
c'était dans le pilote on se souvient
très bien en 72 et fondée donc l'écho
des savanes et après il ya eu le vote a
commencé a commencé cette histoire dogs
parce que les frustrés c'est c'est
monumental lâché à des pages à pilotes
qui ont plu à la rédaction de l'aps la
direction plus tôt
donc ils ont essayé de me faire faire
quelque chose de similaire dans l'ordre
c'est à dire que leurs arguments c'est s
il ya une critique de la gauche radicale
chic vaut mieux que ce soit à
l'intérieur de notre journal alors bon
c'était terrible parce que c'est une
page par semaine vous aviez peur de pas
y arriver parce que comme tous les gens
qui ont du talent vous doutiez et vous
avez déclaré que vous avez dit ils vont
se rendre compte que je suis nue
complexe d'imposture faut passer de la
presse à doha la grande prestigieuse à
l'or fin
jean daniel a déclaré sache pas sur ce
soit vrai mais il a dit grâce à claire
bretécher il est désormais impossible de
se prendre au sérieux au nouvel obs
alors qu'en tant que les gens d'aller à
la police les éditos analyse n'a pas
marché mais ça se passe bien des clubs
si vous n'avez jamais eu de problèmes de
censure truc comme ça non n'est pas été
censuré une fois pas que je sache pas je
me rappelle comme le dira non quoi une
fois vous avez fait un dossier un
dossier vous illustrer un dossier ce
n'est pas les frustrés vous illustrer un
dossier fait par guy sitbon sur le
chômage
et vous aviez fait un dessin de guy
sitbon en train de chercher
désespérément un chômeur s'est passé
s'est passé à sap a été sanctionnée du
tout autant pour moi non non très bien
non mais c'est bien dans sa peau dire
qu'ils ont l'esprit plus large que le
petit écran ils ont l'esprit large
comme ici alors vous êtes quand même
même si vous moquer d'eux d'une façon
extrêmement acerbes
vous êtes quand même un peu
l'incarnation de la gauche caviar non
moi je suis une pauvre dessine gip est
une pauvre dessinatrice à l'époque
maintenant je suis à l'aise dessinatrice
mais c'est tout je vais pas l'impression
de penser à gauche et de vivre à droite
non j'ai l'impression de vivre au milieu
d'eux pense aux milieux d'extrême centre
peut-être voilà vous avez beaucoup
d'humour vous avez déclaré une fois que
j'adore cette phrase j'ai réussi c'est
pas ma faute c'est la faute à la société
sas effectivement quand vous dites des
trucs comme ça on peut pas vous en
vouloir c'est angoulême en vouloir
non j'aimerais bien vous envoie là mais
je peux pas alors ce plan politique
quand même vous avez toujours très bien
sorti parce que vous dites j'ai toujours
été anti gautschi les communistes et les
mao
j'ai toujours trouvé qu'ils avaient un
discours nazi alors aujourd'hui
activement il ya un besoin de sang il ya
plein de gens qui ont écrit des livres
pour dire que le communisme et le
nazisme c'était un peu la même chose
mais à l'époque vous étiez dans le monde
avance donc quand même dès le début vous
avez vu l'imposture gauche histoire que
tout le monde a plongé dedans très
intolérants être violent on avait
l'impression qu'il allait aligner tous
les bourgeois au mur donc des bons nous
on sortait bien en 80 par exemple vous
dit
l'alternance c'est formidable mais je
déteste mitterrand dire que déjà vous
étiez vous l'aidiez après mais ça veut
dire que vous aviez déjà senti tout ce
qui allait se profiler sous les 2 tantôt
n'at il paraît qu'il faut pas dire
maintenant le comté de tess mitterrand
parce que trop de gens le disent
donc je ne dis plus jusqu'à nouvel ordre
je détestais mitterrand de 80 à 85 morts
voilà voilà voilà on voulait pas faire
comme rocard maintenant je laime bien
parce qu' il serait qu'il n'était pas
bien
ouais vous a vu ce qui lui est arrivé à
rocard il a essayé de dire la vérité
tout le monde lui est tombé dessus comme
ça alors est ce que vous êtes que vous
avez jamais été féministe vous plutôt si
je suis pas je suis c'est à dire suis
égoïste donc les féministes revenus non
je suis pas militant je suis pas du tout
- parce que dans tout dans le
militantisme
il ya tellement d extrême l'extrême
ridicule
en tous les cas vous n'avez pas la fibre
maternelle à roanne on vous dira je vous
racontez moi bon d'abord vous croyez
vous pourriez jamais avoir d'enfant vous
disais que cette phrase formidable
qu'ils étaient stériles comme un pavé
dont vous arrêté la pilule c'est ce
qu'on attend c'est croire oui c'est
votre gynéco et vous arrêtez la pilule
vous tombez en simple il aura pris il ya
deux phrases que j'ai relevées comme ça
dans vos déclarations vous dites les
bébés ils savent même pas que vous
existez là où tout le monde dit au
regard des emails me reconnais tout ça
vous dit les bébés jusqu'à chap ok là
ils savent même pas qui vous êtes moche
moi je trouve que tout ce qu'on raconte
le bébé d'une personne faut lui parler
voulait faire entendre du mozart et tous
ont sûrement entièrement mais il ya
franchement un bébé ça donne pas de
réponse non je parle pas uniquement du
mien qui était particulièrement ingrat
oui mais j'en ai fréquenté d'autres
c'était pareil alors vous dites les
enfants on dit toujours qu'ils
grandissent trop vite bien moi non je
trouve qu'ils grandissent pas je vous
fait penser à jacques dutronc parce que
vous êtes beaux tous les deux et vous
êtes doué tous les deux et en fait vous
avez une espèce de comme ça de côté
d'une désinvolture total rien vous
intéresse vraiment c'est sûr du transit
les voyages ça vous plaît pas pourquoi
qui disent ah bah c'est vous qui avez
dit l'exotique nous est dit j'étais en
chine finalement y'a que des banlieues
des immeubles la chine est un pays n'y
sommes voilà ce que j'en ai vu
oui parce que j'ai pas tout vu en lui et
moi mais si j'aime beaucoup les voyages
bon il est là et vous dit un jour j'ai
pris le câblage et j'ai failli vomir
tellement il y avait deux chaînes
arrêtez de regarder vous aimez bien les
pessimistes
non monsieur rend par exemple vous avez
ouvrira ses portes et saint des saints
formidable qui disait sur en disait
la mort me déçoit beaucoup alors bon
dernier point je vous dis tout le temps
je fais pas d'effort pour rester jeune
et belle affaire que vous avez dit qu'à
l'âge de 40 ans vous avez laissé tomber
quoi j'ai perdu l'espoir
j'ai laissé tomber les efforts produits
totalement êtes vous n'êtes pas parti
dans la stratégie jane fonda raquel
welch quoi c'est un boulot à ton cousin
milliardaire mais vous avez quand même
arrêter un peu le les choses un peu un
peu interdite
1 pourquoi vous faites attention à vous
je veux dire vous picoler pas vous n'y
fait rien du tout vous est clean
je bois raisonnablement c'est à dire pas
mal mais on fumait cigarette le reste
non pas de liposuccion pas de silicone
pas de stretching je vous dirai rien bon
d'accord et on va terminer avec une
phrase de vous encore parmi les
aphorismes de claire bretécher que
j'aime bien tout le monde dit je me suis
jamais senti aussi j'aime moi ne
répondait plus même si jamais vous
devriez faire un bouquin de floride non
ouvrées que j'efface pour vous mais je
veux c'est trop fatiguant voilà c'est
bien fait tous les dix ans ouais vous
croyez que vous finirez comme 11 ans
alors l'héroïne de votre dernière bande
ce serait mon rêve ouais ouais c'est une
vieille femme libre ouais elle a la
pêche mais c'est viola maintenant qu'ils
nous donnent des leçons parce qu'ils
n'ont rien à perdre ils ont rien à
perdre c'est bien bon mais ça va j'étais
heureux de vous connaître
j'ai répété le titre du livre que c'est
agrippine et lançait donc c'est le top 5
des aventures d'agrippine 64 pages 64
francs édité par l'auteur merci claire
bretécher des corrections de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus